Börja jobba med kostcaps i Meta eller ska vi bara dra ner vår marknadsföring relativt vad vi trodde eller vad den nu kan vara?
Alltid när jag pratar med människor som dig så känner jag ju att fan vad jag gissar.
Jag tror inte du gör det.
Jag tror att du gör mig vara intitivt istället.
Men är det så...
Nu gick vi in.
Du ska få berätta lite om dig själv.
Men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni...
Vad sa du?
Omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Kenobi-generationen.
Kan du inte ta...
Du vet.
Vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger.
Ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tugga i ögonblicken.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Jakob Bibom Västerberg till podden.
Tjena Jakob.
Tack så hemskt mycket.
Tjena, tjena.
Du är ju rätt hopplös att presentera för att jag inte riktigt vet vad jag ska presentera dig som.
Du har ju ganska många engagemang och ganska många olika områden som du sitter inom.
Vad säger du själv?
Jag skulle säga att mitt primära jobb nu är att jag stöttar eningsbolag i resan någonstans.
Upp till 100 miljoner kronor.
Det behöver kanske vara förbi den punkten också.
Men jag skulle säga att det är det som är fokusområdet.
Sen har jag majoritetsägande i två egna varumärken.
Varav Juniper Eriksson är mer välkänt och det jag lägger mer tid på.
Där min fru är vd och där vi säljer sängkläder och handdukar med mera.
Det är väl det ungefär.
Det du gör är att du hjälper till att skala bolag egentligen.
Ja, exakt.
Jag hjälper till.
Det är så mycket som man kan göra när man ska skala ett bolag.
Jag hjälper till med några av de grejerna.
Det jag hjälper till med är främst på marketing-sidan och sen att jobba med lönsmedelsförbättringar och att frigöra kapital.
Som du vet som själv driver bolag så är kapital när man växer ofta ett problem för bolag.
Det är ofta ett problem som entreprenörer inte brinner för och egentligen inte riktigt har tänkt på förrän de startar bolag.
Sen helt plötsligt, även när man gör vinst, så märker man att det finns inga pengar på kontot och hur ska jag kunna klara att växa nästa år.
Jag försöker hjälpa bolag bland annat att hantera den utmaningen utöver lönsmedelsförbättringar.
Jag tror att det måste vara den mest underskattade utmaningen som bolag har.
Vi har alltid gått vinst och folk tänker att de aldrig har haft pengar på kontot.
Det är alltid tomt på tomt kontot.
Nu ska vi inte hamna i det direkt här men vad är det viktigaste man ska göra för att få in likviditet?
Till att börja med, likviditet består i princip av två saker.
Det ena är att bolaget faktiskt tjänar pengar så det är en viktig start.
Det andra är hur man, för enligt oss bolaget, ofta så har man inte stora capex-investeringar.
Man köper inte fabriker och andra grejer utan det handlar väldigt ofta om att antingen få upp lagenomsättningen eller minska lagret.
Eller fundera igenom hur sortimentet kan anpassas eller att använda sig av intelligenta finansieringslösningar på ett eller annat sätt.
Kunde inte du bara ge oss en enkel lösning?
En mening och så var det klart där.
Så kunde vi bara stänga den diskussionen för all framtid.
Finansieringslösningar?
Finansieringslösningar.
Jag tror att människor är lite skeptiska till det för att det känns som konsumentlån på privatsidan.
Men jag tror att i ett företag går det att hitta sätt att jobba med det och göra att bolaget faktiskt mår bättre.
Men det är klart att det är ännu bättre om man kan hitta ett sätt att jobba utan finansieringslösningar och man istället kan se till att öka lagromsättningshastigheten.
Där finns det också väldigt mycket man kan göra.
Jag tror att framför allt bolag som jobbar med betald marknadsföring i stor utsträckning kan tänka lite smartare runt det för att skapa en högre lagromsättning.
Till exempel på svansen av SKUs som rör sig väldigt långsamt.
Då kanske man får acceptera att man har en lägre effektivitet i marknadsföringen, men 9 av 10 marknadsföringsböror som jobbar med ett bolag kommer alltid bara prioritera de annonserna som får högstroas.
Vilket tenderar att vara de produkterna som rör på sig snabbast och det gör då att lagret i snitt omsätts ganska långsamt.
Alldrig tänkt på det så?
Nej, det kan vara den typen av grejer som jag kan hjälpa till och tänka igenom för bolag.
Ja, okej.
Som jag nämnde här i början, du gör ju ganska mycket så att jag skulle säga att detta tenderar eller riskerar att bli ett lite hackigt inlägg.
För jag kommer ju få hoppa lite i frågorna här till dig så att folk vet om att det är lite planerat.
Så att det är lätt här att sväva iväg.
Men vi ska försöka få med allting och bara mjölka dig på kunskap här under en timme i alla fall.
Absolut.
Kan du inte ge oss lite grann, om vi går igenom din karriär lite grann, vilka är de stora ögonblicken eller de stora bolagen som du har lärt dig saker på?
Eller när vi gör filmen om Jacob, vad är de där fyra scenerna som kommer visas upp i början?
Ja, bra fråga.
Det är så svårt att veta exakt vad man lärde sig av vad.
Ett av mina huvudproblem när jag gick i skolan var att jag hade dålig arbetsmoral.
Jag klarade mig helt okej ändå, men jag hade kunnat göra det ännu bättre ifrån om jag hade gjort lite mer.
Det där har nog olika delar av min karriär avhjälpt.
Det första steget för att få bättre arbetsmoral var när jag jobbade på restaurang.
Under typ en tvåårsperiod började jag plocka disk på Ludmör hotell i gymnasiet och gjorde det tre kvallar i veckan, mellan sex och halv två, jag kan inte förstå eftersom min mamma tillät det.
Då tjänade man kopiöst mycket pengar relativt ens kompisar.
Inte för att det var kopiöst mycket pengar, men om jag hade 10 000 kronor på kontot i slutet på månaden och någon annan kanske fick sitt studiebidrag, då kändes det som att man var rikast i världen.
Det byggde någon form av förståelse för att om man jobbade hårt så kommer det också ge någonting tillbaka.
Sen pluggade jag en massa på högre instanser, möjligen så att senare delen av det när jag gick på handels i Stockholm och läste redovisning, att det faktiskt också hjälpte till att ge en arbetsmoral, för där var det så pass tufft att det krävde mycket tid.
Sen började jag jobba som management-konsult och det är väl det som har format mig mest.
Jag var först på en management-konsult i Stockholm i drygt sju år och sen blev jag ansvarig på business Sweden New York-kontor där jag var i drygt tre år innan jag började jobba med e-handel.
Det är väl de grejerna som har format mig mest.
Varför hamnade du i e-handel?
När jag var management-konsult så jobbade jag ganska mycket mot retail.
Framförallt den andra halvan av min karriär så blev det mer och mer mot retail och jag hade ett jättekul case med Hemtex till exempel, som också var det minsta bolaget jag faktiskt hjälpte under den tiden, men de omsatte kanske en miljard då ungefär och de var i ett skede där de ägdes av ICA.
ICA tänkte divesta Hemtex någonstans, idag äger Kid ett norskt bolag Hemtex istället.
Vi kom in före den transaktionen för att hjälpa till att sätta strategin för framtiden för att göra Hemtex ett attraktivt bolag att köpa.
Det var flera sådana case inom retail som jag tyckte var väldigt kul och i Hemtex fall handlade det väldigt mycket om transaktionen från att sälja i fysiska butiker till att gå online.
Online så är det mer att distribuera eller högre konkurrens i landskapet vilket var en stor utmaning för dem.
Det var väl någonstans där som intresset för retail började väckas och sen så startade då Matilda Juniper tillsammans med mig.
Jag var också med i de första sex månaderna när vi satte upp det.
Sen har ju Juniper varit en verklig del av min vardag, även om jag inte har jobbat med det hela dagarna så har jag absolut jobbat med det på älgerna och det är väl också en del av det jag har lärt med handen genom att faktiskt göra det själv.
Om man lyssnar på din och Fedjas board så pratar ni ofta om Juniper men då får du ju representera Juniper.
Men det är en ganska liten del av din arbetsdag.
Ja men det är väl kanske fyra till åtta timmar i veckan ungefär eller så.
Men det som är bra med Juniper är att eftersom jag är majoritetsägare och har väldigt bra koll på siffrorna så kan jag faktiskt prata om Juniper i podden och använd det för exempel med verkliga siffror.
För jag har både rätt att ge ifrån mig siffrorna och siffrorna i huvudet medans många av de engagemang som Fedja har där är han minoritetsägare och kanske inte har samma möjligheter att lika öppet prata om de bolagen och deras siffror.
Därför blir det ofta att vi faller tillbaka på Juniper som case exempel.
Ja men du gör Juniper och du gör också Inpreble är det andra bolaget som du har varit med och redan sett.
Ja jag köpte faktiskt Inpreble av en annan kille som hade grundat Inpreble.
Men man får väl säga att Inpreble har kommit lite i kläm det här året.
Om jag har fyra till åtta timmar till Juniper så har jag nog haft ännu mindre än det till Inpreble.
Men skillnaden på Juniper är att vi har personal och människor som jobbar med det dag till dag.
På Inpreble finns det ingen personal så det har väl inte varit helt optimalt det här året skulle jag säga.
Och jag hoppas att vi ska kunna få lite bättre fart i det under nästa år.
Nu ser ju inte alla dig här på bild men du är ju en välartad man och du har ju Juniper här.
Varför köpte du Inpreble?
Visst är det preliminära tatueringar fast de håller lite längre?
Ja exakt, de sitter i typ två veckor.
Alla har väl testat gnuggisar vid något tillfälle.
Gnuggisar sitter ju då ovanpå huden, de här sitter i översta hudlagret.
Och en riktig tatuering sitter i andra hudlagret.
Så när det är ett översta hudlagret för nya tjejer så försvinner inte den.
Men du känns bara inte som typen som bara primärt går för det som det här ska jag fokusera på nu?
Nej men det uppkom väldigt randomt det här med Inpreble.
Fedja har i alla fall investerat i en del bolag sedan innan.
Och han driver ju dem delvis med hjälp av sin konsultorganisation.
Det började med att jag och Fedja pratade om att köpa Inpreble.
Och sen så någonstans precis när vi skulle genomföra den här transaktionen så kommer jag och Fedja fram till att vi kanske ändå inte ska jobba ihop.
Även om vi fortsätter driva våran podd ihop.
Och då blev det att jag köpte Inpreble istället.
Men kanske inte riktigt hade fullt tänkt igenom det faktum att det var planerat att vi skulle driva det med ett stort team av konsulter.
Som nu inte längre fanns bakom mig.
Och det gör väl att bandbredden in i Inpreble har inte varit tillräckligt under det här året som har gått.
Jag fattar.
Men upplever du att din arbetsdag är lite rörig?
Det är ganska många bollar i luften här.
Hur planerar du upp det där?
Men det blir lite som att Inpreble och Juniper är två kunder till i konsultlådan.
Det är klart att det kan vara rörigt ibland.
Framförallt så är det mycket meck med kalendern.
Det gäller att hitta tid både till att prata med människor men också att kunna jobba emellan.
Så det blir absolut rörigt ibland.
Sen har jag dessutom tre barn som skapar aktiviteter vilket ytterligare rör till.
Det kan absolut bli rörigt.
Jag tycker alltid att folk säger att barnen har gjort att jag har blivit mer effektiv.
Eller att jag har lärt mig att jobba på något nyss.
Det är definitivt inte bättre.
Det är väl möjligen att när man har barn, att man kanske faktiskt får en timme över eller två timmar över.
Då kanske man är lite bättre på att hålla fokus än de två timmarna.
Man vet att de är svärfulla.
Medan när man inte har barn kanske man bara tänker att man kan flexa ut arbetsdagen så länge man tjänar för.
Okej, jag vet inte.
Nej, jag skulle säga att alla som har barn är fucking casp och jobbar inklusive mig själv.
Ja, kanske.
Jag säger inte emot.
Skulle du kunna ge oss en...
Vi ska inte fastna för mycket i din arbetsdag såklart.
Men kan inte du berätta lite vad du gör på dagarna?
Jag tycker ditt jobb är väldigt spännande.
Det är på något sätt det jag hade velat göra själv.
Du vet, komma in och ut i företag, få komma in med lite punktinsatser där och lite så där.
Kan du inte ta oss med lite vad du jobbar med just nu om du får säga något?
Ja, absolut.
just när det är september och oktober, vi spelar in 9 oktober.
Då handlar det väldigt mycket om budget.
Budget är in för nästa år.
Jag är ofta djupt involverad i de kunderna som jag jobbar med i att sätta den budgeten för nästa år på en väldigt detaljerad nivå.
Det handlar ofta om att bygga stora Excel-modeller och sen verifiera inputs och antaganden med våra kunder.
Samtidigt ska man inte glömma bort att 9 oktober har man fokus på att förbereda Q4.
Det är en annan del av det.
Men nu med Orange Juice har vi fördelat det mera.
Så att Oscar är här och nu och jag kanske blickar några månader fram, i alla fall på de klienter vi jobbar parallellt.
Det är väl mycket av min vardag just nu.
Men generellt annars kan det vara nu på en av de kunderna som jag jobbar så ska vi starta ett cost out-program eller ett margin improvement program.
Nu håller vi på att förbereda det lite under hösten och sen ska vi dra igång det på allvar nästa år för att försöka realisera GMEQM2-förbättringar under nästa år.
Måste man ha budget?
Eller när måste man börja ha budget?
Jag tror att man blir bättre på att driva tillväxt och lönsamhet om man sätter upp en budget.
Jag sätter inte en budget som en vision.
Så kan man också använda en budget.
Säg till sitt team att nästa år ska vi till 100 miljoner och det kommer bli fantastiskt.
Då försöker man använda det för att motivera människor att ta sig nånting.
Det är inte det jag försöker göra när jag gör en budget.
Jag försöker egentligen göra en forecast vad som är extremt sannolikt att hända nästa år om vi beter oss som vi har gjort under de sista två åren.
Om de mönstren fortsätter, var kommer vi då att landa nästa år?
Sen är jobbet nästa år att gå ut och slå det som är sannolikt kommer att hända.
Då har man förbättrat sina avslut på något sätt.
Jag tror att det är värdefullt för när man gör uppföljning en viss månad så säger man att vad konstigt, vi hade förväntat oss att det skulle komma 300 återköp från tidigare kunder.
Men det kommer bara 200 återköp.
Då är det antingen någonting fel i vad vi har gjort den månaden eller så är det någonting fel i forecastingen.
Either or så lär man sig nånting.
Eller så har vi en möjlighet att återaktivera de kunderna på något annat sätt under de kommande månaderna.
Så det ger någonstans en feedback loop till en själv att fundera på vad jag är dålig på att bedöma eller har jag gjort ett dåligt jobb.
Utmaningen är någonstans alltid att det är både forecasting och execution som blir väldigt viktigt när det kommer till budget.
Så jag tror att därför är det bra med budget och sen tror jag också att det är ett extremt bra redskap för att driva lönsamhetsförbättringar i en resultatsräkning.
Vad är det som blir?
För nu nämnde du till exempel återkommande kund.
Det hade jag nog aldrig tänkt vara med i en budget.
För mig är det bara en kund.
Hur många människor tänker lika level 1 som jag gör?
Hur avancerad måste budgeten vara för att den ska vara rimlig?
Vad är viktigt?
Hur nördig måste man bli?
Hur mycket tid måste man lägga på det här budgetarbetet?
Jag tror att om man vill göra det väldigt enkelt för sig.
Det som är riktigt viktigt ändå är att separera upp GM3-bidrag från återkommande kunder och ny kund.
Om man jobbar med betalmarknadsföring.
Men om de bolagen jag stöttar jobbar alltid med betalmarknadsföring.
Eftersom många pratar om begrepp som att man ska vara lönsam på första order.
Men kanske inte jätte lönsam på första order utan man är helt okej med att det är break even.
Men om man nu säger att man ska vara det, det står aldrig en budget någonstans.
Men om du följer upp slutet av månaden så säger du att du har belånat 100 000 kronor på att skaffa nya kunder.
Men vi har fått en miljon i bidrag från återvändande kunder.
Då har du en feedback loop från marketingteam eller den personen som rattar din betalda marknadsföring.
Vad var det som gick fel den här månaden?
Vi sa att vi skulle försöka hålla oss över noll.
Dessutom säger man att vi vill hålla oss över noll varje enskild vecka.
Då borde de fyra veckorna som är en månad lägga ihop till nåt positivt.
Man lyckas inte matcha noll varje vecka.
Om man då har landat minus 100 000 kronor, det beror lite på hur stort bolaget är.
Om man omsätter 100 miljoner i minus 100 000 månader så spelar det inte så stor roll.
Men om bolaget är relativt litet så är minus 100 000 kanske betydande från nykundsanskaffningen.
Då måste man fundera på vad vi gör annorlunda nästa månad.
Ska vi börja jobba med kostcaps i meta eller ska vi bara dra ner vår marknadsföring relativt vad vi trodde eller vad det nu kan vara?
Alltid när jag pratar med människor som dig så känner jag ju att...
Fan vad jag gissar mycket.
Jag tror inte du gör det.
Jag tror att du gör mycket att vara intuitiv istället.
Men om jag skulle börja...
Vi omsätter ungefär...
I år kanske vi landar på 85-90 eller nåt sånt där.
Och jag har ju aldrig gjort en budget utan allting går ju bara på...
Ja, det här blir säkert bra.
Och jag gissar att det är rätt många.
Jag gissar att det inte är många bolag du kommer in i som omsätter under 50 miljoner.
Som bara...
De här orden du precis sa med en GM3 positivt på första kunden och andra...
Det är väl ingen som tänker på det där någonsin.
Är det där man börjar?
Är det starten?
Starten är såklart att du har en netto-omsättning och någonstans ett mål...
Ja, låt oss bara hoppa över att folk fattar att någonstans ska det vara omsättning minus typ inköp.
minus lite kostnader.
Och så är det klart att det är grundparameter i en budget.
Men sen menar jag att det första steget för att skapa detaljering i en budget...
Då menar jag inte att du måste forecasta att du ska få 273 återkommande kunder i februari.
Men däremot att säga att i februari...
Det som är relativt enkelt ändå är att uppskatta hur många återvändande kunder som kommer.
Det är lättare för vissa bolag och svårare för andra.
Ju mer sällanköpt det är, desto svårare det tenderar att vara.
För din kundbasbransch är det svårt att bedöma det.
Det är inga konstigheter.
Jag gissar att det är ganska lätt för alla.
Det är hyfsat enkelt.
Det som är svårare är att uppskatta hur många nya kunder som kommer att komma in.
Det beror på så otroligt mycket saker och hur mycket marknadsföringseffektivitet du hittar och hur snygga annonser du gör.
Men om man börjar med återkommande sida.
Om vi säger att nästa år gör ni 100 miljoner.
Sen kommer du och jag efter lite analyserande fram till att av de 100 miljonerna så tror vi att 60 miljoner kommer att komma från kunder som handlat från dig tidigare.
Och så har du ett GM2-bidrag från dem bara för att förenkla nu på 50 %.
Så då vet vi att när jag säger GM2 på återkommande kund.
Det är för mig egentligen lika med GM3.
För jag attreberar ingen betalmarknadsföring till återkommande kunder.
Ett GM2-bidrag på 30 miljoner från de 60 miljoner återkommande som du ska ha nästa år.
Det är lika med 30 miljoner i GM3-bidrag från återkommande kunder.
De andra 40 miljonerna ska komma från nya kunder.
Då har vi ett GM2-bidrag på dem på 20 miljoner.
Men så tar du din marknadsföring och så ponerar vi att du gör av med 20 miljoner på marknadsföring.
Då har du ett GM3-bidrag från de nya kunderna på noll.
Då har du ett totalt GM3-bidrag på 30 miljoner.
30 % av 100 miljoner.
Och då kan du börja fundera på om du kan betala med personal och lokaler och vad du är nöjd med det.
Om du har antingen någon inhouse som skattar in betalda marknadsföring eller om du har en byrå som gör det.
Då kan du verkligen hålla dem efter den punkten att säga att det är fine nästa år om vi inte når 100 miljoner.
Det är helt okej om det blir 95.
Men det är inte fine om det är minus 10 miljoner på GM3-nivå på nykundsanskaffningen.
För då kan du inte betala dina räkningar.
Då är det i det fallet väldigt tydligt från din sida att det som är prioriterat i GM3, hurvida vi landar på 95 eller 105, det är sekundärt till det faktum att det ska vara noll i GM3-bidrag från nya kunder.
Det ger dig möjlighet att betala räkningarna eller göra en utdelning till dig själv eller vad du kan tänka svara som är prioriterat.
Hur kommer det sig att du inte räknar inom marknadsföring på återkommande kunder?
Det är en förenkling av verkligheten.
Självklart är det så att när vi går ut på Meta och visar annonser så kommer en del av de annonserna hamna på återkommande kunder.
Men om du frontloadar, om du tänker på en enskild kunds resa hos dig, om du frontloadar all marknadsföring mot nya kunder, då kommer det på ett sätt vara orättvist dyrt att skaffa nya kunder.
Det gör att du har ett konservativt estimat på hur mycket pengar du tjänar på den här kunden från start.
Det är otroligt mycket lättare att göra uppföljning, excella, etc.
Även om det är så att om vi satt oss ner skulle säkert 5-10% av marknadsföringsbudgeten gå mot återkommande kunder.
När du driver dina egna bolag, Juniper och Increble, eftersom du är van vid att tänka på det här sättet som konsult eller som rådgivare och sånt där, kan du uppleva att det blir en krasch, att du vill bli lite för nördig, lite för snabbt eller du vill tänka lite för stort, lite för fort eller lite för långsiktigt?
Ganska mycket av entreprenörsresan upp till 100 miljoner är ju ganska mycket bara att det här blir bra eller vi testar det här.
Kan du uppleva att du är lite för analytisk för den situationen som du är i?
Absolut.
Jag är nog en bättre rådgivare till ett bolag som omsätter mer än 50 miljoner egentligen än till ett bolag som omsätter under 10 miljoner.
Jag är inte bäst beskaffad att hjälpa riktigt små bolag.
Med Increble är det helt meningslöst, men alla såna här restauranger är bara helt useless, för Increble är så litet.
Juniper som nu kanske gör 17 miljoner i år, där någonstans börjar det ändå finnas en poäng i att göra den här typen av uppföljningar.
Jag har väldigt tajta forecasts mot vad som faktiskt händer.
Det gör att vi kan planera anställningar, det gör att vi kan planera hur mycket vinst vi ska göra nästa år.
Vilket tycker jag är en fördel.
Jag tycker det är behagligt när saker och ting är stabilt och faller ut ungefär som man förväntar sig.
Jag köper det.
Vad tror du att det är, med all respekt, vad tror du att det är för förmågor som du saknar?
Vilka förmågor som till exempel Matilda har som är på andra sidan, vilka egenskap som en entreprenör har som inte handlar om budget och forecasts och detaljstyrning och liknande.
Jag tror att jag är ganska dålig på att göra enkla arbetsuppgifter.
Arbetsuppgifter som är tydligt definierade, som kan skrivas upp på en to-do-lista, som vissa tycker är topp på sin to-do-lista, för att de går att checka av snabbt.
Men jag får mycket hellre än arbetsuppgift på min to-do, som är att jag ska bygga upp en marketing mix-model som jag aldrig har byggt innan för ett bolag som har någon ovanligt komplex marknadsföring.
Jag vet inte hur jag ska ta med an det här problemet riktigt, det behöver researchas, det behöver göras och det kommer ta en vecka att avsluta.
Det tycker jag är toppen.
Men när du säger till mig att du kan uppskjata vår marketing och sen så kan du börja mullade upp de här fem annonserna.
Det tenderar jag att ha väldigt svårt att göra, antingen så gör jag fel eller så glömmer jag bort att skriva headlinesen eller så är det någonting annat.
Att driva ett bolag handlar till 90% om ganska enkla arbetsuppgifter, där man behöver göra den ena efter den andra och hålla upp i humöret, snarare än de här relativt få komplexa arbetsuppgifterna.
Så jag tror att det är en grej, jag har massa brister, men det är en av de grejerna som gör att jag skulle ha svårare i det dag till dag.
Ja men jag köper det.
Det är ju väldigt mycket, jag vet inte, att slå huvudet i väggen brukar ju folk säga.
Det är lite åt det hållet ja, det är bara att plöja på typ.
Men är det det här som gör att, för det finns ju extremt mycket beroer och det finns väldigt många, vad ska man säga, experter inom e-handel.
Men det är ganska sällan som de själva driver en e-handel eller är duktiga på att det driver en e-handel eller gör det stort.
Är det det här de saknar eller varför startar inte bara alla duktiga rådgivare sin egna e-handel och bara omsätter några miljarder.
Jag tror att svaret på den frågan, det finns nog lika många svar på den frågan som det finns konsultbyråer.
Men om du ska generalisera och trasha lite på konsultbyråerna.
Du sa ju själv att du har ändå drivit ditt bolag lönsamt, i hur länge då?
Sen 2016 köpte jag det, så åtta, nio år.
Det är alltid tomt på kontot, trots att du växer mot 100 miljoner.
Det en e-handel inte är är att det inte är en särskilt effektiv metod att extrahera värde för de flesta personer.
Det är klart det finns en success case som typ kan göra det.
Jag gillar det, bra svar.
Det borde alla faktiskt ta till sig.
E-handel låter som att det växer fort att man tjänar pengar men det gör man fan inte om man inte är en av 300.
Alla konsultbyråer som överlever i princip har möjlighet att göra utdelningar i slutet av året.
Om jag gör en miljon i vinst så kan vi dela ut 800 000 kronor för att det binder inget kapital.
Jag behöver bara lite extra pengar på kontot för att kunna hantera om någon kund försvinner.
Jag måste betala någon extra lön i förväg.
Men det binder väldigt lite kapital.
Där får man möjlighet att göra utdelningar.
Det är en rationell anledning till att driva ett konsultföretag snarare än ett e-handelsföretag.
Det är nästan som att alla vi e-handlare sitter här i någon sorts hamsterhjul påhejad av konsultbyråerna som bara plockar ut pengar på.
Det som är svårt med en konsultbyrå är att få till ett likvideringsevent någon gång.
Det är väldigt svårt att sälja bolaget för det finns konsultbyråer som säljer, men jag har aldrig förstått idén att köpa en konsultbyrå.
Du köper ett gäng människor, en fjärdedel slutar samma dag som du köper.
Sen binder du fast tre grundare eller två grundare inom ett treårsavtal.
Samma dag som avtalet går ut säger de hejdå och lämnar.
Idén att köpa konsultbyråer är dålig.
Idén att köpa ensbolag kan vara bra.
Men det är ganska få förunnat även på den sidan när det kommer till ensbolag att faktiskt sälja sitt bolag någon gång för 100 miljoner eller för life changing money.
Nu pratar vi bara om kapitalistiska skäl till att gå in i konsultning snarare än e-handel.
Jag tror inte att det är så många som tänker på det här.
Men det här är också ett sätt att tänka på det.
Sen tror jag att många går nog in i det för att man tycker att någonting är väldigt kul att jobba med.
Jag tycker att det är väldigt kul att jobba med att göra finansiella förbättringar och jag tycker att det är kul att jobba med marketing.
Jag är bättre på att jobba med det finansiella än med marketingen.
Men jag tror att det är väldigt viktigt idag som konsult att inte bara göra en sak.
Jag tror att det är väldigt bra att göra mer än en sak för då kan man få mer värde för sina kunder.
Jag tycker att det är väldigt problematiskt när marketing beror.
Det enda de gör är att dra meta-budgetar upp och ner och inte ha en förståelse för att det finns ett lager bakom och vi kan ha kassaflödesproblem.
Det finns en hoop av problem.
Det sätter otroligt höga krav på bolagsgrundaren i stället för att kunna driva det.
Marketing blir dem på ett effektivt sätt.
Jag önskar att bli lite mer strategisk och kunna ha en diskussion med grundaren om att jag ser det här och det här och gör det så här så kanske det finns förbättringspotential framåt.
Exakt, du ser att det snarare är som någon sorts advisory board, inhoppad styrelse fast konsultbasis.
Problemet med styrelser är ofta att de handlar om så långt ifrån bolagen.
Framför allt om de har en styrelse som inte har jobbat med exakt det du gör.
Då är det otroligt svårt för styrelserna att ge väldigt konkreta tips.
Men när jag är inne och jobbar med ett bolag och det kanske ligger minst en dag i veckan på det här bolaget, till slut kommer jag kunna deras siffror väldigt bra.
Då blir man bättre på att problemlösa med den vd.
Annars sitter man så enormt långt upp i en helikopter och pekar med hela handen att de ska åt något håll.
Men är man där och ser siffrorna och förstår problematiken, då är det lättare att bli den speaking partnern till vd.
Jag köper det, absolut.
Jag skulle säga att du har varit med ganska mycket utifrån och varit med i ganska många affärscaser.
Både från den här tiden och även när du var i business Sweden.
När du tittar på ett bolag som har gått från 10 till 100 miljoner eller 200 miljoner eller ännu mer.
Vad är det man inte inser när man är 10 miljoner att man kommer behöva vara bra på i takt med att man växer?
Vad är det oftast folk inte fattar eller börjar med för sent eller tar tag i?
För det första tror jag att när man går från noll till tio, så tror de flesta inbillade sig när de är på noll.
Att när de är på tio miljoner tror de att de kommer driva ett ganska stort bolag.
När man väl kommer till tio miljoner, det låter så mycket tio miljoner.
Men när man väl kommer till tio miljoner så inser man att man har knappt startat och det fortfarande är en låda där man kanske är två personer och man sitter och tittar på varandra och funderar på om man ska överleva.
Och sen när man tar sig från 10 till 100 miljoner så tror jag att i konkreta termer så är det en grej som man inte fokuserar så mycket på med tio miljoner kronorsbolagen.
Det är just det vi pratade om med kapital eller working capital.
Men som för nästan alla bolag som gör resan 10 till 100 miljoner helt plötsligt blir väldigt verkligt.
För när man är på tio miljoner då är beloppen fortfarande ganska små och det är lite lättare att gå till allmän.
Man kan låna 500 000 kronor någonstans.
Men helt plötsligt om man ska upp till 100 miljoner och man behöver finansiera lagring och köp på fem eller sex eller tio miljoner då är det inte alltid riktigt lika enkelt.
Så det tror jag är en sån grej som alla får lära sig på något sätt den hårda vägen om de inte har tänkt igenom det innan.
Hur tänker man igenom det från start?
Absolut att man lär sig det under vägen och man hittar ju sina modeller och sitt sätt.
Men finns det något sätt att riktigt bygga upp ett bolag från start utan att ta in sjuka mängder kapital som gör att man faktiskt inte får det här jävla problemet?
Eller är man bara dum?
Är detta en del av det?
Det beror lite på.
Jag tror att du till exempel har nog lite mer utmanande produktmarginaler än vissa andra e-handelsbolag.
Driver du ett e-handelsbolag och vill säga att du säljer mobilskal i stället bara för att ta något exempel där jag inbillar mig att de har kokainmarginaler då har du 10% av din net revenue som produktkostnader då är det väldigt lätt att jobba med extern finansiering för att förlänga antalet betaldagar.
Så ponera att vi ska köpa in någonting första januari och din fabrik kräver att du betalar samma dag som orden ska skickas.
Men du vet att du kommer inte omsätta ditt lager mer än kanske två gånger per år.
Det tar 180 dagar innan du gör av med de där produkterna.
Då hade du ju idealt velat betala fabriken först efter de 180 dagarna när du har sålt hela lagen.
Man kan nog betala längs vägen, men det är klart att idealt hade man gärna betalat när hela lagen hade försvunnit.
Ska du finansiera det och du använder Trade eller Extendo eller Unis säkert då kanske de tar 1% i månaden.
1% i månaden låter ju som en ocheränta eller det är ju någonstans en ocheränta.
Men samtidigt 1%, sex månader, säg att det är max 10% med ränta på ränta över tiden.
Det som tidigare var att produktinköp som kostade 10% av nettoomsättningen om du har 10% extra på det, då är det 11%.
Så din produktmarginal går helt plötsligt från 90% till 89%.
Inte jätteproblematiskt.
Så helt plötsligt har du satt dig i en situation där du binder noll kapital när du växer.
För länge någon är villig att fortsätta finansiera det där allt eftersom du blir större och större.
Men eftersom du aldrig binder nåt kapital i lager så kommer ju istället då en massa cash på ditt bankkonto som du potentiellt kan använda för att fortsätta backa upp den finansieringen.
Så det är väl ett kreativt sätt att jobba med som jag tycker är bättre för bolag som har starkare produktmarginaler än bolag som har mindre starka produktmarginaler.
Säg att man har en skitmarginal.
Vilka andra områden är det man ska jobba med, förutom...
Du sätter dig lite på kortkanten här.
Det är helt fajt.
Det är mitt jobb någonstans.
Om man har en jättedålig marginal från början det kanske inte är en riktigt bra idé för att en så staträkning fungerar att vara så komprimerad.
Där har vi funderat på om det är nåt med discounting-strategin som är problematiskt.
Vi rensar bort allt i det sortimentet för att det rör på sig för långsamt.
Dessutom har de sämre marginalstruktur på de mesta av de produkter som finns i det.
Det kommer både att hjälpa till med att frigöra kapital och dessutom förbättra marginalstrukturen långsamt.
Det är ett sätt att jobba med det.
Sen kan man fundera på prissättningen.
Prissättning är en grej.
Man har en väldigt bred skrufora.
Man kanske har jättesmarta sätt att jobba med prissättning men det kan också finnas förbättringspotential i hur man tittar på sin prissättning.
Det beror helt på om man säljer sina egna produkter eller andra bolags produkter.
Det är svårare att göra prispensmarker om man säljer sina egna produkter.
Men då handlar det om någonstans om du har lyckats bygga upp Brand Equity för att få pricing leverage på varumärket och din kredibilitet.
Det finns många sätt att tänka på det.
Det behöver inte vara fel att använda sig av de finansieringar.
Om du omsätter ditt lager på...
Jag vet att du nämnde i våran podd att du omsatte lager 2,5 gånger per år ungefär.
Hade du haft 60 eller 90 betaldagar från att du får produkterna här hem till Sverige så måste man inte titta på 180 dagar cykelfinansiering.
Men hade du finansierat ut det 90 dagar så hade du kunnat sälja en stor del av det lagret innan du skulle betala fabriken.
Det hade nog direkt gjort att det kändes lite enklare.
Jag hade behövt dyka in i det innan jag fick se om det hade varit en bra idé.
Men det finns ju andra mindre extrema punkter än att finansiera hela tiden om du tar att omsätta lager.
Hela förra året skulle jag säga att min största arbetsuppgift var att pusha betaltider hos leverantörer.
Det var det jag gjorde förra året.
Det var det som gjorde att vi växte förra året.
Jag sa nog inte ens det, men det är klart att man kan gå tillbaka till fabriken och prata om betaldagar.
Det är steg ett i den här ekvationen.
Där kan man också hitta lönsamhetsförbättringar.
Om man inte har att man måste betala vid första orden och du har gott om pengar på kontot då kan du titta på att ta bort betaldagar från din fabrik för att få kassarabatt.
Sen finansierar du upp de betaldagarna i Sverige.
Om din leverantör är i Asien och på sin sida finansierar den ekvationen, och du har 90 betaldagar och så finansierar de det för 2 % i månaden.
Sen säger de att du kan få 6 % rabatt om du betalar samma dag som vi skickar orden.
Sen går du tillbaka till Trade eller någon annan finansieringsplattform.
Vad kostar det om jag ska ha 90 dagar av serier?
Då säger de 3 %.
Då har du hämtat hem 3 % i lönsamhet med exakt lika många betaldagar.
Det är också en möjlig lösning.
Ja, en jävligt trevlig lösning också.
Du sa också att du jobbar en hel del med marknadsföring.
Vad skulle du säga är den stora grejen där?
När många börjar med marknadsföring så är det typ att man lägger upp ett Instagram-inlägg och så försöker man skriva till tusen människor.
Sen börjar man göra hela meta-grejen och lite Google-grejer.
Men vad skiljer de, quote marks, riktiga bolagen från en liten hobbylåda på två pers?
Vad är det man börjar tänka på?
Vad är det man gör bättre?
På meta...
Väldigt många varumärken driver sin tillväxt med betald marknadsföring på meta.
Det finns absolut exempel på de som lyckas med TikTok och det finns exempel på de bolagen som har väldigt stark inband på Google.
Men majoriteten av varumärken har metas med väldigt viktigt tillväxtliv.
En av de enkla men svåra arbetsuppgifterna någonstans för att få meta är ju volymen av creatives som du sätter in i motorn.
I början tror jag att man tenderar att sätta större fokus på kvaliteten i varje enskild creative.
Jag säger inte att det är oviktigt, men nånting som alla de som är stora har förstått är att de har ganska svårt att bedöma innan ett creatives sätts live om det faktiskt kommer att vara framgångsrikt eller inte.
Så att volymen av creatives är otroligt viktig.
Att bara gå ur sig mycket, testa mycket och sen se vad som lyckas och inte.
Det är väl om man tittar på typ 9pine till exempel som har blivit relativt väl dokumenterade nu som Facebook-genier och de pratar om att de lanserar 200 annonser i veckan.
Det är klart att man kan komma till den typen av volym, vilket måste vara superjobbigt att managera, men då har man väldigt goda förutsättningar att lyckas växa.
Eller i alla fall att inkrementellt förbättra sin förmåga att växa på meta.
Det börjar någonstans med att du ska ha en produkt som människor vill ha.
Idealt är det en produkt som människor vill köpa igen.
Vi bara förutsätter att allting är hygienmässigt okej, men så lite grann en numbers game att man behöver steppa upp det helt enkelt.
Det är i alla fall en av de grejer som bolag gör.
Sen skulle jag säga att jag jobbar inte alls med creative production.
Det är inte det jag säljer, men jag tydliggör ändå för bolag att det är en viktig del av det.
Sen behöver de lösa det på ett eller annat sätt, antingen in house eller med hjälp av någon annan byrå eller liknande.
Sen tror jag i själva medieköpet, lite det som vi öppnade upp den här dialogen med, där finns det också mycket man kan fördelar av en slagor som ska gå iväg snabbare.
Det är väldigt lätt idag eftersom meta förespråkar en konsoliderad struktur, att man ska lägga in alla annonser i en kampanj och sen bara se vad som fungerar bäst.
Det är ju bäst för algoritmen, för då får den själv bestämma vad som funkar bäst.
Problemet är bara att då kommer den alltid prioritera de annonser som människor reagerar på mest positivt.
Det resulterar i att en fraktion av ditt sortiment säljs.
Men i Unipers fall, som ofta är Anders exempel, så där vi har sängkläder, vi har handdukar, vi har morgonrockar, tvåla, handlotion.
Om jag lägger in alla de här i en annons och ber Meta maximera antalet konverteringar, då kommer den bara sälja tvålburkar, för de kostar 250 kronor.
Det är lättast att övertyga någon att köpa något för 250 kronor istället för att köpa något för 5 000 kronor om man ska köpa kläder till en hel säng.
Men Unipers revenue består ju för 80 % av människor som ska köpa sängkläder till en hel säng.
Så det är ingen bra metod för Unipers.
Om jag då i stället säger åt en att maximise value, då är det i och för sig diffust och beroende på hur bra annonsen är, då kanske det bara prioriterar sängkläder.
Men då får vi aldrig sälja våra tvålburkar.
Så jag måste ju hitta en annan strategi då jag ser till att Meta kan spendera både på att hitta människor som vill köpa sängkläder och tvålburkar och få båda de kanalerna lönsamma.
Detta med en custom lifetime value-profil är ganska annorlunda för de här kategorierna.
I alla fall om man bara tittar på kategorierna enskilt och inte tänker på kortsförsäljningen för att du kan få mer återkommande kund med tvålburkarna.
Där kan människor ta slut på sin burk hos köpa igen.
Sängkläder köper man kanske en gång var fred i år eller vad det nu kan det kan vara.
Är det inte positivt att få ett 99-1% i ett sortiment där kunderna verkligen hårdköper vissa produkter?
Då kan du alltid pusha dem mer mot leverantörer, du kan göra större inköp.
Om du ändå jobbar på en internationell marknad där det inte kommer ta slut närmsta åren med kunder.
Jag säger inte att man inte ska göra det.
Om vi tar ett exempel att vi har optimerat Metapotent, vi säger maximize value i metakampanjen.
Jag säger inte att vi inte ska göra det, men då kommer jag aldrig sälja den här tvålprodukten.
Jag vet marginalstrukturen där, jag vet vilken kack jag kan tillåta när människor gör det i köpet.
Men om jag bara gör det får jag bara återkommande kunder var tredje år.
Om jag vill sälja handdukar, morgonrockar, tvål och handlöshen för att uppkasta mig lifetime value.
Återkommande via e-mail, jag vet att du inte gillar att skicka e-mails.
Men oavsett så kan man aktivera människorna via e-mail.
På det sättet kan jag skapa en bättre lönsamhetsprofil på den enskilda kunden potentiellt.
Skulle man kunna säga att oavsett hur man styr sin marknadsföring, för du ger ett argument för att gå åt ena eller andra hållet, men min upplevelse är att folk inte tänker på det över huvud taget.
De har ingen strategi, utan man går in och hoppas att man får ett sälj, men man tänker inte på om säljet är det högmarginalprodukter eller lågmarginal, eller återköpande produkter, utan man bara spray-and-pray och hoppas att nånting händer.
100 %.
De flesta marketing-byråer, eller vem som helst som driver ett metakonto, tittar på ROAS, som ger ett mått av hur mycket...
Roas som är i Meta inkluderar ju dessutom Moms, vilket gör det mer skit.
Det här är inte det enda måttet du tycker om.
Det är ett mått, men ett ganska svagt mått på att lista ut vad du ska göra i ditt metakonto.
Det är det absolut vanligaste.
Det kan mycket väl visa sig att två annonser med olika ROAS som har helt olika marginalstruktur, och framförallt när du lägger in shipping, blir det totalt olika outcomes för bolaget.
Det finns ingenting som garanterar att den annonsen som har högre ROAS ger mer lönsamhetsbedrag än den som har mindre ROAS.
Det enda det säger är att vi behöver dämona färre marketingkronor relativt Revenue plus Moms, vilket är ett mått.
Som vi alla vet har en resultaträkning en Gm1, Gm2 och Gm3.
Du kan inte bara titta på om marketingen blev 18 eller 20 % för att bedöma om en enskild order blev lönsam.
Det är inte ens nära verkligheten.
Jag sitter nu med en marknadsföringsbyrå och de säger att din ROAS har gått upp från 3 till 3,5 och du har större omsättning.
Hur ska man börja kravspeza mot en byrå för att faktiskt få pengar på kontot och växa lönsamt?
Allt annat lika.
Om vi säljer exakt samma sak och ROASen har gått upp och bara att vi säljer mer av det, då är det klart att det är bättre.
Då lägger vi mindre marknadsföringspengar på att få fler nya kunder eller spara pengar på hur man väljer att göra.
Det är väl bra så.
Men jag tror att det är väldigt viktigt för en marknadsföringsbyrå att förstå lagerpositionerna till att börja med.
Vad har vi mycket av?
Vad har vi lite av?
För att inte sällan så är det så att det som säljer beredst har man lite av och sen har man inte hunnit restocka.
Då pushar marknadsföringsbyrorna ändå den produkten som går bäst på meta hela vägen in i kaklet tills den tar slut.
Sen får du restocka om tre veckor.
Men vad som hade varit en mycket bättre lösning då, om vi ändå vet att de här produkterna säljer så bra, det hade varit att inte lägga en krona på marknadsföring på dem.
Sen hade det tagit dig tre veckor extra att sälja slut på de produkterna, men då maximerar du marginalbidraget.
Då har du noll marketing på de produkterna när de säljs.
Sen skulle du i stället lägga dina marknadsföringspengar på någonting som du har mycket mer kvar av i lager.
Det gäller som marknadsföringsbyrå att få, eller det gäller som bolaggrunder först att tydliggöra vad det är jag försöker göra.
Man måste ge ett väldigt tydligt mål.
Idealt säger man då till exempel att jag vill maximera min försäljning givet att GM3 från nya kunder är noll.
Det är ett bra randvillkor att ge till en byrå.
Sen kanske dessutom lägga in en period i det och säga att jag vill inte ha en enda vecka med negativt GM3-bidrag från nya kunder.
Eller jag vill inte ha en enda månad med negativt GM3-bidrag från nya kunder.
Ge man ner randvillkort säger man, men inom den parametrarna vill jag växa så mycket som möjligt.
Då vet marknadsföringsbyrån vad de ska jobba med.
Det som möjligen kommer in från sidan är lagret, om man vill vända någonting.
Om du tänker på ett klädbolag, många klädbolag rear ut produkter när det blir sommar.
Då rear de ofta ganska aggressivt också, 30-50% för att bli av med sina produkter.
Men om man i stället hade sagt i marknadsföringsbyrån i maj att det är helt okej att sälja den här delen av sortimentet med en råast på 2, då är det fine.
Då pushar man in mer pengar mot någonting som marknadsföringsbyrån upplever är dåligt.
För om de hålldes mot en råast, då hade det varit katastrof för dem.
Men det är mycket bättre för dig att sälja till en råast på 2 än en råast på 3.
I stället för att när det blir juli är det 50% rabatt på det här sortimentet.
Jag älskar det argumentet.
Jag hoppas folk verkligen förstår det argumentet.
Man måste förstå att rea ut en sak eller göra mer marknadsföringsbyrån är typ samma grej.
Det blir samma kostnad, så man behöver alltid sätta i relation.
Tjänar jag mer om jag bara råmarknadsför detta, om det ändå ska säljas av då, eller om jag sänker priserna på det.
Ganska ofta är det råmarknadsföring som funkar, och då slipper du sänka priserna.
Det kan påverka andra grejer positivt också.
Det tycker jag är ett jättebra råd.
Jag hoppas folk verkligen fattar att det är ett jättebra råd, så börja använda det om du inte använder det.
Det låter konstigt för människor ofta när man säger att vi ska sänka kraven här under våren, så blir de missnärjda, men det är bättre.
Dessutom får du in pengarna direkt.
Det finns så många vinnningar av det där.
När du kommer in så här utifrån, upplever du att de andra byråerna upplever att du är lite av en asshole som helt plötsligt kommer med massa krav och kravställningar?
Ja, lite kanske.
Så är det nog.
Hur långt ska man pusha det där kontra personlig relation med sin byrå och sina samarbetspartners?
Hur jobbig ska man vara?
Jag försöker väl balansera det så mycket som möjligt, men jag kommer alltid ta bolagets sida.
Jag har två kunder just nu där jag jobbar som advisor, men det är en annan byrå som sköter metakontot.
I båda de fallen fungerar det ganska bra, men jag ger mycket mer instruktioner till dem än vad bolagen själva gjorde innan.
Det gör att det blir mindre low touch för byrån.
Det ideala för en byrå är att man har sett den få gett och att det blir lite jobbig timmar.
Då blir det en extremt lönsam kund för byrån.
Men jag ger mycket instruktioner, kravbilder och funderingar på vad vi borde stänga av och förändra.
Ibland är det inte alltid positivt att man gör massa förändringar heller, men det gäller att tänka igenom vad man driver för outcomes.
Jag kan säkert tänka mig att de sitter på sin sida och säger att det här är jättejobbigt.
Så får det väl vara då.
Var någonstans hämtar du in kunskap eller var håller du dig uppdaterad?
Du pratade själv om att du ville ha lite mer bredd eller att du var lite bredare än bara ett ämne.
Då är det också ganska svårt att vara sjukt kompetent och antagligen kommer du ändå in i bolag där grundaren eller ägarna ändå är intresserade.
De har ju antagligen lite kunskap, så du behöver ju ändå toppa över det eller toppa åt sidan eller ha något annat perspektiv.
Vad kommer kunskap ifrån för dig?
Jag tror att grunden kommer nog från att jag har jobbat med väldigt många jättestora bolag.
Där problemen har fler nollor efter sig, men det finns också då när du kommer in på ett jättestort bolag då sitter det 14 personer på finansavdelningen och så måste man sitta och diskutera med de 14 om deras problem.
Medan på ett bolag som har satt 50 miljoner kanske finns en eller ingen som sitter på finansansvaret.
Jag tror att typiskt sett är kompetensnivån då lägre på ett bolag som är någonstans i den här storleken 20-100 miljoner.
Jag tror att det ganska ofta går att bidra med värdet så, men sen det jag och Fedja pratar om är nästan uterslutande marketing tactics i vår podd.
Det behöver man i mycket större utsträckning underhålla för det förändras från vecka till vecka och det sker uppdateringar på plattformarna och så där.
Det håller jag mig uppdaterad på genom podcasts företrädesvis och läser en del nyhetsbrev och så där.
Jag konsumerar extremt mycket content relativt nästan alla.
Jag skulle tro att jag är i översta 2% av människor när det gäller att konsumera content.
Jag springer mycket och lyssnar på mycket material men jag springer i ganska hög tempo så jag konsumerar 5-8 timmar e-handel slash marketing content varje vecka.
Det är klart man inte minns alltid, men man minns vissa grejer och sen kan man diskutera om de sakerna.
Jag vet att du skulle springa en marathon i veckan eller något sånt där.
Var det något gammalt mål du hade?
Ja exakt, nu springer jag till och med lite mer än det men det var ett mål förut i alla fall.
Jag känner mig gött gubbfet här.
Svårt att tro det ändå.
Hur ofta är problemet grundaren eller vd när du kommer in med de här, du börjar prata budgetar eller marknadsföring.
Hur ofta är det en person som jag som sitter där och bara budget det skiter jag i och så är det egentligen jag som är problemet?
Jag gör i princip ingen cold outrage alls.
Det gör ju att det finns någon form av survivor bias eller vad man ska kalla det för.
Att de människorna som kontaktar mig, de har väl hört en del av mina idéer eller fått tips av någon eller vad de nu kan tänka svara.
Är det inte att de bara vill få en klappa axeln och känna att de gör saker rätt?
Det ger jag ganska sällan så jag tror inte att jag inte är rätt person då.
Jag fattar.
Skulle du säga att du kan, vi tar detta som avslutande fråga så ska vi fortsätta dagen där sen.
Men skulle du säga att när du kommer in i ett bolag och hjälper till, upplever du att du har koll på om de här kommer bli bra eller de här kommer fortsätta växa eller det här kommer skita sig?
Kan du känna det?
Jag kan som regel bedöma det ganska snabbt om jag börjar titta på siffrorna om de är i en bra position idag.
Sen kan man alltid fundera på vad det går att göra för förbättringar.
Alla förändringar kräver ofta ganska mycket och det är inte alltid enkelt.
Ibland kan man tro att man kan göra förändringar som man inte sen klarar av att genomföra.
Det lättaste är att de bolagen som redan går bra går i regel att säga att det här kommer vi nog kunna fortsätta göra bra.
Det är lite 50-50.
Jag känner att jag inte riktigt besvarar frågan på ett bra sätt.
Okej, vi säger så här då.
När du kommer in i ett bolag och så har de tagit in dig där och du går in och så känner du att här finns det massa grejer jag kan göra.
Men i grunden är detta dödstömt.
Vad är det som gör att det är dödstömt?
Det finns många grejer som kan vara dödstömt, men en extremt dålig marginalstruktur kan vara en sån grej.
Jag kom in till ett bolag nyligen som jag nu hjälper i för sig.
Men som på något sätt har haft dåligt samvete för att göra prishöjningar över de sista tre åren.
Så de har inte gjort några prishöjningar.
Det har gjort att deras GM1 har gått ner och ner och ner.
För att de underliggande kostnaderna har gått upp.
Bolaget investerar ingenting i marknadsföring alls och är just breakeven men har svårt att växa.
Och har en relativt liten uppväxt.
Då är det klart att man ska kunna komma tillbaka till en punkt där man kan börja växa igen så måste man hitta ett sätt att ta in nya kunder.
De nya kunderna kommer antagligen behöva komma genom marknadsföring eller andra organiska medel.
Så då behöver vi omstrukturera den här resultaträkningen lite grann.
Men när du har glömt att prishöja i tre år.
Då är det inte så att du kan mejla ut till alla dina kunder och säga att jag har inte gjort det här på tre år.
Så by the way nu höjer jag med 45% imorgon.
Det kommer ingen att köpa.
Utan någonstans får man börja med att säga att vi höjer 10% across the board.
Och så kanske vi hittar några utvalda produkter där vi ligger väldigt billigt mot konkurrenter.
Och höjde om lite mera.
Så får man börja en resultaträkningsomskruvning.
Som gör att vi nu kan investera kanske 5-8% av Net Revenue i marknadsföring.
Och så får man hoppas på att man får lite effekt på det.
Det tenderar ju att vara så att de första kronorna som har spenderat i marknadsföring får bäst effekt.
Så att ofta får man en positiv vind i ryggen i början.
Men det här kommer vara ett flerårsuppdrag någonstans att strukturera om resultaträkningen och se till att de får en bättre marginalstruktur.
Men i grund och botten har de en bra produkt.
Och då en produktstund som en K verkligen gillar.
Så då går det att göra någonting.
Om man vänder på det och säger att det är ett bolag som har 200 kronor i A och V till exempel.
Det har i och för sig mobilskalsföretagarna.
De växte så stora väldigt snabbt vilket jag tycker det är svårt att förstå.
Men typiskt sett om man har väldigt låga A och V så är det svårt att hitta en bra ekonomi i nya kunder.
För det är svårt att hålla ner i kacken på 40-60 kronor på meta och olika skala med det.
Så det kan vara sådana där grejer som gör att man bara känner att det här är ett bolag som kommer ha svårt att tas förbi 10 miljoner.
Det här är liksom ett 5-10 miljoner kronor bolag för all framtid.
För de kan inte riktigt göra den där pushen.
Och då när den organiska effekten avtar eller de lyckas hitta fler nya kunder.
Det bolaget kanske är på något sätt dödsdämt till bemärkelsen att de aldrig kommer kunna växa ordentligt.
Jag fattar.
Jag köper det.
Om man märker att ens priser inte kan följa med i materialutvecklingen och inflationen och liknande.
Då har man liksom ett problem i grunden och då behöver man hantera det problemet på något sätt.
Det känns fullt rimligt.
Det känns som en ganska bra sammanfattning.
En tråkig sammanfattning men en fullt rimlig sammanfattning.
Det är någonting i alla fall.
Om jag får några metrics på ett bolag.
Om jag får reda på vad deras AV är.
Det är inte alltid ett bra mått för att det är ett average.
I juni har vi massor av människor som beställer för 1000 kronor och 5 000 kronor.
Om man tittar på grossmarginalen eller GM2.
Jag får first order profit relativt kack.
Kanske din customer lifetime value på 365 dagar relativt vad du har för first order.
Om jag får de fyra metrics.
Då ska jag säga att jag i väldigt många fall kan bedöma om det här bolaget har goda förutsättningar för att växa snabbt eller inte.
Ser det alltid bra ut och ändå bolaget inte riktigt har lossnat.
Då går det oftast att hitta en lösning på det.
Då ringer man dig.
Då ringer man mig så kan vi problemlösa runt det en timme och se om vi kan hitta några sparar på att göra det.
Jag får säga ett stort tack Jacob för det är det isärklass nördigaste avsnittet som jag har haft hittills.
Jag hade lite svårt jag var tvungen att zooma ut ibland för jag kände att fan jag kunde grotta ner mig här i 40 minuter till.
Jag tycker sånt här är ganska kul men det finns ju någon stackare som inte tycker det.
Ett stort tack för att du var med.
Stort tack.
Jättekul att vara med och skapa ett nördigt avsnitt.